[Musica]
visual c quanti di voi sanno cosa
significa questa parola data va bene
quanti di voi hanno fatto almeno una
volta nella vita ha vinto la cinica ma
lo spiego pure agli altri big thing è un
termine nato abbastanza recentemente che
indica l'attività di guardare una
puntata dietro l'altra di una serie tv
senza interrompersi mai
per capirci quelli che hanno alzato la
mano lo sanno e la classica maratona da
divano ci mettiamo le guardiamo un
episodio con un altro ancora per un
altro ancora poi un altro ancora e non
ci fermiamo mai
oggi grazie a strumenti come netflix e
tanti altri
infatti è cambiato il modo con il quale
usufruiamo dei prodotti seriali le serie
di bug o di altro tipo non dobbiamo più
aspettare una settimana come succedeva
prima per un nuovo episodio ce l'abbiamo
tutto lì e vogliamo guardare uno altro
ancora un'altra cosa tutti a portata di
un clic sul nostro telecomando e se ci
pensate qualcosa di molto simile
capita anche con gli oggetti grazie a
strumenti come amazon prime
di cosa avete bisogno di un libero di un
paio di scarpe di un accessorio per il
vostro smartphone
qualsiasi cosa voi abbiate bisogno
potete ottenere il giorno dopo in alcune
città addirittura nella stessa giornata
dopo poche ore ancora una volta tutto lì
a portata di un clic sul nostro
smartphone in questo caso e vogliamo
parlare del cibo cosa volete mangiare
stasera voglia di pizza preferita usciva
di un hamburger da mangiare pasta carne
dovete solo scegliere avete tutto a
portata di un clic sul vostro smartphone
grazie a strumenti come just eat
e che dire del sesso potete saltare la
trafila di uscite imbarazzanti di serate
dove non sapete cosa dire dei due di
picche imprevisti oggi si può ancora
volta abbiamo tutto lì a portata di un
clic sul nostro smartphone con strumenti
come tindari penso che uno degli impatti
più grossi che abbia avuto
il digitale la tecnologia in generale
sulla nostra vita soprattutto negli
ultimi anni e in termini di velocità la
velocità con la quale riusciamo ad
ottenere le cose queste che aveva
mostrato tindara eccetera
sono solo alcuni dei tanti strumenti e
applicazioni sistemi aziende che hanno
letteralmente abbattuto le barriere tra
noi ei nostri desideri bar ieri in
termini di spazio ma barriere
soprattutto in termini di tempo
io penso a questa cosa più credo che
stiamo vivendo un po all'epoca del del
tutto e subito
noi ci stiamo abituando a questa cosa
che avremo lo smartphone c'è un'app
possiamo ottenere una cosa lo stiamo
iniziando andare per scontato un pochino
questa cosa del tutto e subito
gli americani che ovviamente hanno un
nome per qualsiasi cosa chiamano questa
tendenza che abbiamo negli ultimi anni
con nome di instant gratification che
significa gratificazione istantanea se
non avete mai sentito questo termine vi
faccio un esempio faccio vedere che
cos'è la dedicazione istantanea la
doppia spunto a blu di whatsapp e tutte
le le problematiche che ha introdotto
questa singola novità ditemi che non è
mai capitato a qualcuno dico di guardare
il vostro smartphone in particolare di
guardare whatsapp aprire una chat e
pensare o dire la frase ha visualizzato
ma non ha risposto con con tutte le
conseguenze che questa frase porta nella
nostra mente no in termini di
arrabbiature di congetture di pensieri
di incazzature che ci facciamo solo
perché qualcuno ha visualizzato ma non
ha risposto credo che col digitale sia
succederà nella rosa stiamo iniziando a
confondere la velocità del mezzo con la
velocità del fine e questa cosa è
terribile perché ci sta dando dentro di
noi che grazie al digitale cioè c'è una
sottile illusione di successo come se
grazie al digitale il successo fosse
alla portata di tutti come se fossi
quasi dovuto e veloce rapido immediato
ammessi solamente un illusione
ci siamo ci siamo circondati di di
metriche di vanità per alimentare questa
illusione e quindi viviamo l'epoca nella
quale contiamo i like contiamo le
condivisioni con tramite tweet contiamo
i follower in un momento qualsiasi uno
di voi può aprire lo smartphone e
condividere qualcosa sono dei social
media e avere un risultato immediato
avere un riscontro immediato avere
quella
modificazione istantanea di cui parlavo
prima e paradossalmente quando non ce
l'abbiamo
insieme ad arrovellarsi su cosa è nato
storto e quindi è perché sto facendo
così pochi like perché nessuno sta
commentando o peggio ancora perché
quella persona è affatto il follo che
non è più un mio amico
sapete qual era la faccenda
la cosa più assurda di questa faccenda
il nostro cervello quando si trova in
questa situazione di gratificazione
istantanea è stato provato che produce
una sostanza che si chiama dopamina la
dopamina ci fa stare bene ci dà una
bella sensazione quindi più ne
produciamo più ne vogliamo
se non avete mai sentito parlare della
dopamina la dopamina e la stessa
sostanza che viene prodotta quando
formiamo quando beviamo alcol quando
scommettiamo
tutte cose che ancora turisti che hanno
una caratteristica in comune che la
dipendenza e questa illusione successo
lentamente credo che sia un pochino
alimentata anche dai media negli ultimi
anni con il racconto continuo di storie
di persone di ragazzi che razza al
digitale sono arrivati al successo molto
molto velocemente sono diventati ricchi
fin da giovani penso alle mie spalle
sono dei tanti nella storia mark
zuckerberg il fondatore di facebook
pensava la conosciamo tutti quanti non
devo raccontarvi la via verso uno dei
tanti lui è ivan spiegel il fondatore di
snap chat con una storia molto molto
simile a quella di mark o ancora kevin
systrom il fondatore di instagram ancora
una volta una storia molto simile a
quella dei due precedenti oppure se
vogliamo prendere un esempio tutto uno
strano tutto italiano
la fashion blogger più famoso del mondo
la nostra chiara ferragni storia di
questo tipo non sono più solo nemiche di
settore come succedeva in passato ormai
sono ovunque diventando molto spesso dei
punti di riferimento se non addirittura
un metro di paragone soprattutto per i
più giovani soprattutto pieri per i
ragazzi e poi a questo mondo potreste
dirmi che magari sta roba voi non mi
riguarda non vi tocca a voi siete
diverse tutto questo che ho detto a voi
mi tocca e potrebbe essere così magari
avete ragione però potrebbe riguardare i
fratelli e le sorelle potrebbe
riguardare i vostri figli potrebbe
riguardare i vostri nipoti
ci sono studi scientifici soprattutto
negli stati uniti d'america negli ultimi
anni chiave dimostrato che questa
tendenza alla grande applicazione
istantanea al tutto e subito sta avendo
un impatto devastante
i giovani se sulle nuove generazioni dai
millennials in poi avendo un impatto
devastante e le nuove generazioni
ragazzi giovanissimi ormai hanno sempre
più hanno sempre meno autostima un senso
di insoddisfazione perenne di
inadeguatezza perenne una mancanza di
fiducia nella vita privata ma
soprattutto in quella lavorativa visto
che di quello che stiamo che stiamo
parlando oggi questo ne è solo un
esempio
non so se avete mai visto questa questa
ragazza che si chiama lisette le sette
salita alla ribalta della cronaca
qualche mese fa per un affare che
surreale lei si era appena trasferita a
new york e si è letteralmente riempita
di debiti in pochissimo tempo per
comprare cose oggetti vestiti gioielli
solo per potervi mostrare nelle sue foto
su instagram una storia sul real lo
ripeto si è riempita di debiti per
comprare oggetti da mostrare nella sua
foto su instagram perché lei sarà tra
sfidano york e quindi voleva vivere una
vita da star
anzi oggi diremmo una vita da influencer
poco importa che in realtà aveva messo
in piedi una falsa perché quella vita
non le apparteneva anzi paradossalmente
lei non poteva nemmeno permettersi da
quella vita non avevo i soldi ma non le
interessava no perché le voleva il tutto
subito o il risultato immediato voleva
la gratificazione istantanea di cui
parlavo prima
sapete cosa credo credo che un po alla
volta stiamo perdendo l'uso della
pazienza stiamo iniziando a dare per
scontato questo tutto e subito
e siamo anche diventando dipendenti da
questa questa gratificazione istantanea
con easton e creatrici cation come la
chiamano come la chiamano dagli
americani ma non confondetevi quando
parlo di pazienza la pazienza non ha
nulla a che fare con con la lentezza con
l'immobilità la pazienza per come la
vedo via e visione è il riuscire ad
investire nel lungo periodo darsi degli
obiettivi nel lungo periodo ma forse
avete mai sentito il famoso discorso di
steve jobs a stanford si fa una metafora
bellissima dice nella vita non puoi
unire i puntini guardando in avanti ii
poi unite solo guardando indietro però
ad un certo punto devi avere fiducia che
potrai fermarti indietro e unire riunire
queste puntini
ecco perché è fondamentale tenere in
considerazione la parte attiva della
pazienza e la costanza
mentre la parte passiva e la pigrizia la
pazienza non è semplicemente il saper
aspettare cosa facciamo mentre
aspettiamo
e lì la differenza e allora forse
dovremmo raccontare più storia di
costanza dovremo raccontare di come
questo signore alle mie spalle che si
chiama jack ma il fondatore di ali baba
è stato rifiutato dieci volte ad harvard
prima di fondare la sua azienda alibaba
e poi diventare l'uomo più ricco della
cina oppure raccontare di come questo
signore che si chiama peter vesterbacka
il fondatore di rovio aveva lanciato 51
giochi senza successo la sua azienda era
vicino al fallimento e poi ha ideato
anche herbert che è diventato uno dei
giochi più famosi della storia oppure
raccontare di come brian acton questo
altro signore alle mie spalle
il fondatore di whatsapp quando cercava
lavoro è stato rifiutato prima da
facebook e poi da twitter poi deciso di
fondare la sua azienda whatsapp è la
venduto a facebook per 19 miliardi o
raccontare di come le a busca la
fondatrice di tasca rabbit abbia dovuto
cambiare il business modo della sua
azienda decine di volte litigare con gli
utenti inferociti con il consiglio di
amministrazione di dimettersi da ceo
dell'azienda ma poi alla fine riuscire a
vendere la sua azienda ikea e
rivoluzionare un settore intero
cosa hanno in comune queste quattro
storie due cose
il focus su un obiettivo e l'amore per
il processo perché io credo che la
differenza in fin dei conti sia
veramente li nell'amare il processo
quello che fai nel innamorarsi del
processo perché pc il processo è la
parte concreta e la parte attiva
quotidiana operativa della pazienza
il processo molto spesso è già il
risultato il processo sono i piccoli
step che giorno dopo giorno che ci
portano il risultato
il processo sono i punti di cui parla
steve jobs volevo condividere con voi
4 motivazioni scritto quattro vantaggi
secondo me per il quale dovremmo
riappropriarci di questa capacità
perdute di questa pazienza perché
dobbiamo recuperare la pazienza come la
motivazione sono tante ma ho provato ad
elencarne 4 la tolleranza la latenza ci
tende tolleranti verso gli errori verso
gli errori
degli altri ma soprattutto verso i
nostri ed errore dopo errore noi
l'abbiamo solamente più esperienza
diventiamo anche più resilienti e
ricordiamoci che il famoso percorso di
cui parlavo prima processo parlavo prima
non deve andare per forza una sola
direzione
a un certo punto dobbiamo avere anche la
forza e il coraggio di ammettere con le
stesse che stiamo sbagliando e cambiare
rotta
il secondo il tempo la pazienza è
l'unico modo che abbiamo per recuperare
il tempo che è una cosa sulla quale
siamo completamente perdendo il
controllo negli ultimi anni è in realtà
è una cosa che strettamente collegata
con la nostra salute mentale quindi con
la nostra felicità
le decisioni la pazienza è l'unica arma
che abbiamo per prendere decisioni
ponderate per avere il focus sul
presente ragazzi sul momento attuale
riuscire a valutarlo in base a quelle
prendere una decisione
volete migliorare le vostre performance
di business lavorativi iniziata da
questo è il quarto e ultimo la pazienza
necessaria per imparare per ammettere
con noi stessi che non sappiamo tutto
che non conosciamo tutto ea volte
dobbiamo darci il tempo di imparare le
cose e allo stesso tempo però dobbiamo
imparare ad avere pazienza
perdonate il gioco di parole
ricordandoci che le le cose belle e
importanti della vita non avvengono
davanti alla sera in un giorno il bear
amore la vera amicizia.il in questo caso
il successo lavorativo e la carriera
la pazienza è un'abitudine e in quanto
tale dobbiamo allenarla
come si allena la pazienza come facciamo
ad allenare questa pazienza se
cominciamo a procedere giuste domande si
cominci a mandarci degli obiettivi nel
lungo periodo
avendo però la capacità di spezzettarle
in tanti piccoli obiettivi nel famoso
divide et impera godendoci questi
piccoli obiettivi chiudendoci questi
piccoli successi quotidiane in età degli
insuccessi quotidiano volendoci il
processo il percorso
proviamo a cambiare la narrativa
iniziamo a parlare di risultati invece
che è successo perché se volessimo fare
una metafora sportiva non stiamo
correndo i 100 metri da che stiamo
correndo una maratona stiamo correndo
una maratona e una volta che abbiamo
capito questo credo che la chiave del
successo o meglio forse dovremmo dire la
chiave per i risultati sia veramente
facile
credo che sia veramente facile per chi
ricerca la gratificazione istantanea
quando non la ottiene
abbandono alla gara ed è lì che sente la
differenza perché in un contesto dove il
99 per cento le persone abbandonano alla
gara vince che ha pazienza
terza la francese
[Applauso]
[Musica]